bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soir le grand mal être du monde paysan
alors que le salon de l'agriculture
ouvre ses portes dans quelques jours la
profession est toujours en profonde
souffrance faiblesse des revenus
faiblesse des retraites crise des
vocations sans compter les coupes
budgétaires à venir dans la politique
agricole commune des négociations
serrées sont d'ailleurs en cours ce soir
à bruxelles agriculteurs comment sortir
de l'impasse
on en parle ce soir dans notre grand
débat rien ne va plus à l'assemblée sur
les retraites les débats s'enlisent dans
d'obscurs bataille de procédure les
esprits s'échauffent aussi avec cette
menace du 49-3 qui devient plus forte
que jamais retour en images sur les
temps forts de cette tragi-comédie dans
l'hémicycle avec en plat tôt l'éclairage
du constitutionnaliste dominique
rousseau enfin notre grand témoin ce
soir est une femme engagée elle et
économistes géographes aussi écrivain
elle a travaillé pendant plus de 15 ans
dans l'humanitaire elle publie
aujourd'hui un manifeste contre la
grille bashing sylvie brunel est avec
nous ce soir voilà pour le programme
sans oublier bien sûr notre nouvelle
chronique qui veut prendre sa place sur
la campagne américaine signée françois
durpaire
ça y est vous savez tous ces partis
hashtag sévère n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
choisi lcp nos invités en plateau ce
soir sylvie brunel bonsoir merci d'être
notre grand témoin vous avez un parcours
pour le moins éclectique vous êtes
géographe professeur des universités 15
ans dans l'humanitaire je le disait
médecins sans frontières action contre
la faim vous et dvd chevaux dans la
drôme
ils ont été malheureusement pause au nez
mais bon ah bon aulas c'est triste vous
êtes l'auteur de nombreux livres sur
l'afrique la famine le développement et
vous publier ce livre ce petit livre
vert pourquoi les paysans vont sauver le
monde c'est chez buchet chastel volicon
vous les voyez comme ça les paysans
comme des sauveurs comme des héros mais
pourtant ils souffrent on va en parler
ce soir notamment avec vous jean
baptiste moreau bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député la république
en marche de la creuse
vous aussi vous élever des bovins cette
fois ci dans ce même département
marc le fur bienvenus vous êtes député
les républicains des côtes d'armor et
rodolphe marconi bonsoir à vous merci
d'être là
vous signez un portrait documentaire qui
sort en salles mercredi prochain de
lettres réalisateur le titre de ce
documentaire cyril agriculteurs 30 ans
20 vaches du lait du beurre des dettes
on enverra un extrait merci à tous les
trois à tous les quatre pardonnez moi de
participer à ce ça vous regarde en
direct vous connaissez la formule celui
qui nous plante le décor avec son ton et
son regard pour commencer cette émission
c'est stéphane blakowski son billet tout
de suite si j'ai bien compris
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane installez-vous si j'ai
bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris myriam les agriculteurs se
sentent mal aimés a tellement parlé même
forgé un nouveau mot pour tenter de
décrire cette hostilité dont ils se
sentent victimes on appelle ça la ghriba
ching bon intense et l'as rome à la fin
normale compréhensible il ya trois
quarts des français qui vivent
aujourd'hui en ville ont finalement la
campagne bat ils la connaissent surtout
parce qu'en dit la télé en vérité qu'est
ce qu'elle dit la télévision à la télé
qu'est ce qu'elle dit la télé fait son
métier elle nous alerte et nous dit
attention on utilise des pesticides et
du coup elle risque d'impasse et les
agriculteurs pour des empoisonneurs puis
elle dénonce aussi les conditions dans
certains élevages au risque évidemment
que certains éboueurs passent pour des
monstres insensible résultat les
agriculteurs qui sont déjà minoritaire
dans ce pays de 2 %
bah là ils se sentent ni carrément au
ban de la société alors évidemment comme
jean-baptiste moreau qui est avec nous
avant d'être député a été agriculteur il
est toujours en noir
non ils auront tellement à jean baptiste
valais on vous aime les agriculteurs
vous savez un tous les sondages de 10 85
% de bonnes opinions pour les
agriculteurs de la part des français 74%
des français qui nous font confiance
je signale que des journalistes les plus
forts dire autant nous le 40% de
confiance sur ce que les gens disaient
la télé qu'est ce qu'il vous faut de
plus et un grand discours d'amour pas de
problème le président macron sait faire
des déclarations d'amour alors celle de
2020 il bat la fère au salon mais qui
l'avait déjà fait l'an dernier donc on
écoute sel je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
de plus sensibles à la maltraitance
animale qu'un éleveur parce qu'il vit
avec ses bêtes parce que celui qui se
réveille la nuit quand il ya un village
celui qui se lève avec l'anxiété
quand la maladie arrive c'est l'éleveur
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi
ambitieux pour le changement climatique
le réchauffement qu'un agriculteur parce
que celui qui en vit des conséquences
chaque semaine chaque mois qui tremblent
devant la sécheresse qui vit les
conséquences de l'inondation
c'est l'agriculteur effectivement y met
du coeur c'est une déclaration d'amour
mais justement myriam je vais vous dire
c'est ça le problème parce que c'est
parce que tout bon mais l'amour ça
n'existe pas la seule chose qui existe
ce sont les preuves d'amour est donc là
forcément le ministre lui il revient
donner des preuves d'amour à ses
agriculteurs
il leur a fait un petit cadeau 1
observatoire de la grille bashing pour
recenser en réalité les actes
malveillants contre les agriculteurs
créer un observatoire c'est ça une
preuve d'amour
oui c'est pas vous imaginez vous auriez
reçu un observatoire pour la saint
valentin vous auriez contente
un vrai cahier dans lequel noter tout ce
qui va pas non franchement on a besoin
d'autre chose qu'ils ont besoin d'amour
évidemment les agriculteurs mais ils ont
surtout besoin d'argent
alors on dirait oui on en est tous là
sauf que dans le cas des agriculteurs et
les études une qui publie en 2016
notamment qui dit qu'un tiers des
agriculteurs qui touchent moins de 350
euros par mois donc le chiffre est
contesté
mettons que ça soit même le double mais
donc un tiers des agriculteurs touche
700 euros par mois pour un accès
suffisant non bon alors elle a lu
ministre lui donc il se bat pour
défendre l'image des agriculteurs mais
quand il s'agit de défendre les revenus
des agriculteurs
bah là il a un petit peu impuissant il
ya pourtant une loi qui était votre
temps des 1018 s'appelle et galim donc
essentielle peut équilibrer les rapports
entre producteurs par agriculteur et
grandes surfaces sont ces gens c'est
porteur je vois bien déjà que rien que
de prononcer le nom ça crispe un peu
mais on va vous dire que je vous dit
ministre a été honnête puisque lui-même
il la reconnaît que reconnus par contre
les effets de la loi se devait encore
attendre c'était au sénat novembre 2019
grande difficulté qui dit à pour
l'agriculture c'est que les agriculteurs
sont la seule profession en france qui
ne fixe pas leurs prix la seule
profession qui vend en dessus et en
dessous de ce que ça leur coûte et c'est
inacceptable
depuis 15 ans tous gouvernements
confondus la france n'a pas réussi à
donner un revenu décent à ses
agriculteurs
et c'est là le drame pour tous les
agriculteurs ne vivent pas dans la
misère comme un ya des grands
exploitants agricoles dans ce pays a
grand culte heures et agriculteurs à
celui qu'on aime bien le petit
producteur de fromage bio dans les
pyrénées avec ses 150 moutons celui-là
on adore et puis les autres les grands
exploitants agricoles qui font triompher
la france à l'international qui
contribuent au succès de commerce
extérieur et dont on se méfie énormément
des ans et un buzz va qui tourne en ce
moment a été lancée par mediapart sur
les salaires de certains cadres de la
fnsea qui touche pour certains plus de
10000 euros brut par mois donc la fnsea
christiane lambert a dû se défendre ce
matin nous assumons la politique
salariale de nos dirigeants nous avons
besoin d'experts de haut niveau nous
sommes à paris et les nous avons donc
besoin de cadres de haut niveau
alors y'a pas exactement christine
lambert le profil de
l'agriculture qu'on était dans une pub
pour vanter un terme en berne par
exemple moi c'est aussi ça c'est un
métier c'est une injure pas une
industrie mines une grosse activité
économique donc on a fait le buzz autour
de ça avec mediapart est un autre
article on a moins commentée qui donne
la croix aujourd'hui une étude en saône
et loire
donc je pense que ça vaut pour toute la
france qui dit que 77% des agriculteurs
travaillent plus de 50 heures par
semaine et qu' ils ont deux fois plus de
chances de faire un burn-out que
n'importe quel champ de chefs
d'entreprise qui est déjà très exposé au
phénomène donc oui ils ont besoin
d'amour si possible en espèces sonnantes
et trébuchantes merci ça excellent
billet aurait dit c'est vrai on va faire
sortir on va on va partir peut-être
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses dans
le papier stéphane avec vous si les
promesses sur cette agri bachini vous
enrage cette agri bashing dans votre
caddie la première phrase c'est celle ci
réalisons nous tous que nous devons à
nos paysans nous les maltraitant nous
les ignorons d'où les méprise ont
pourtant ils nourrissent
il ya une forme d'ingratitude dans la
société vis-à-vis du monde agricole
d'ingratitude et d'amnésie d'ingratitude
parce que si notre france est belle si
notre france est forte et notre france
exporte et qu'elle est vécue comme un
pays
nourissier pour les classes moyennes
émergentes du monde c'est grâce à cette
agriculture française familiale
diversifiée avec à la fois des
productions végétales et des productions
animales un pays qui ne qui est beau
grâce à ses campagnes
et puis le deuxième problème c'est que
nous avons au sujet de nos agriculteurs
des idées reçues qui datent souvent
d'une vision passer d'une vision très
nostalgique
alors qu'aujourd'hui être agriculteur
c'est être un chef d'entreprise c'est de
voir et vous l'avez dit c'est de voir
arbitrer avec des normes de plus en plus
nombreuses des contrées larmes
environnementale et norbert des normes
sanitaires ça c'est écouter il nous
protège de maux dont nous avons oublié
l'existence est ce que je dis dans ce
livre c'est attention aux retours des
pénuries et des contaminations
l'agriculture là la question alimentaire
est en train de devenir stratégique est
un enjeu de santé publique un danger au
silence du rhône magique
oui mais un enjeu stratégique aussi sur
le plan nourricier la deux
d'alimentaire s'accroît de 15% tous les
dix ans donc vous vous dites en fait
c'est un peu la grèce mais alimente en
eau françois on aurait dû mais on
importe de plus en plus parce qu'on fait
en grève
nos agriculteurs corps redoutable voilà
on greffe nos agriculteurs de tout un
ensemble de contraintes de plus en plus
longues on en importe au nom des prix
plus intéressants en provenance de pays
qui s'autorisent des choses que nous
n'autorisons pas nos agriculteurs en
matière de molécules en matière de génie
génétique en matière de pratiques que
nous ne voulons pas les côtes d'armor
par exemple c'est un département
exemplaire c'est un département dans
l'agriculture était extrêmement
performantes les bretons ils ont inventé
brittany ferries pour nourrir la grande
bretagne
les bretons c'était des gens qui étaient
pauvres c'était des cheveux cette
présence
et pourtant nous attend là quand vous me
dites pas que j'ai en tête les algues
vertes le problème est que vers ton les
impute toujours au pays sans alors que
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer tous les
noms mis en avant que des montres il
s'est hissé à y servent de boucs
émissaires
vous savez que si la bretagne faisant
passer en circuits courts paris meurent
de faim il parie ce nom avec les côtes
d'armor qui est un très beau départ
comment vous dites qu'en fait il ya il
ya une forme d'injustice et de
méconnaissance et d'ingratitude et
d'amnésie et vous dites en même temps
que c'est l'une des thèses de votre
livre marché pour le climat s'est
d'abord marcher pour l'agriculture
expliqué nous ça je vous expliquais pas
pour un an contre intuitif livernon mais
pas du tout les agriculteurs il occupe
quasiment deux tiers du territoire
français c'est à dire qu'ils pilotent
les paysages selon la conduite d'une
exploitation vous aller capter
énormément de dioxyde de carbone
vous allez préserver vos sols un champ
maïs une un verger une vigne ça va
capter plus de co2 qu'une forêt livrée à
elle-même je peins pas d'effort est
jeune et bien entretenus chaque fois
qu'un paysan la schl à faire c'est la
friche c'est l'embroussaillement les
paysans ce sont les artisans d'une
biodiversité qui est d'autant plus
importante qu'elle et nourricière et
nous avons besoin d'abord et avant tout
de nous nourrir
donc les côtes d'armor donc la creuse 2
paysage totalement différent mais où
l'agriculture joue un rôle absolument
essentiel dans la déclaration d'amour
pourtant il ya un paradoxe les français
les aime les agriculteurs voire depuis
des années les enquêtes ne se démonte
pas premièrement le grand sur salat et
en même temps voilà il ya quand même des
insultes parfois même des agressions
physiques
il ya quand même de plus en plus cette
idée qu'il nous empoisonne aussi mais il
y à il ya un manque de connexion avant
il ya ne serait-ce qu il ya 20 ou 30 ans
tout le monde avait un oncle une tante
un cousin agriculteurs aujourd'hui c'est
plus vrai avec la diminution du nombre
d'agriculteurs même dans des
départements très ruraux comme le mien
comme à guéret dans la creuse
là où je me suis fait le plus attaqués
depuis le début du quinquennat c'est
parce que j'ai refusé d'interdire le
d'inscrire l'interdiction du glyphosate
dans la loi et par départ des gens sur
le marché de guéret parce que il ya une
déconnexion complète entre le monde
agricole et pas que le monde urbain et
le reste du monde je dirais aujourd'hui
effectivement on a bâti une image du
monde agricole qui n'est pas celle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
pourquoi les agriculteurs ont produit
toujours plus dans la fin des années
sorti de là de la guerre parce qu'il
fallait produire pour nourrir la
population donc ils se sont adaptés à ce
que la société leur demander aujourd'hui
la société elle demande aux 112
apparemment autre chose mais le patent
de l'agriculture c'est pas le temps le
pas de temps des médias il faut lui
laisser le temps de s'adapter à cette
nouvelle demande du consommateur elle a
déjà commencé sur l'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires elle a déjà
beaucoup diminué il ya d enregistrer il
faut surtout des pas de temps qui sont
compatibles avec ce qu'est l'agriculture
aujourd'hui on va venir dans un instant
sur le quotidien concret d'un
agriculteur celui que vous avez
rencontré ce cyril dans un instant mais
voilà nouveau salon de l'agriculture
demain c'est toujours le même problème
c'est pas compliqué c'est toujours la
faiblesse extrême des revenus c'est
toujours la faiblesse extrême des
retraites et cette crise des vocations
d'ici 3 à 5 ans 30 % des exploitations
agricoles pourraient mettre la clé sous
la porte ce sens entrepreneurs 50 % des
exploitations européennes vont être
soumises à la succession c'est à dire
les noms dont les chefs d'exploitation
du prennent leur retraite d'ici cinq ans
qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut se
permettre ça en france qu'est ce qui va
se passer la place et que le
l'emploi ce n'est pas simplement de
l'agriculture c'est tout ce qui va avec
dans un département comme le mien et je
vous remercie de m'avoir fait l'éloge
c'est pour un employé agricole il y a
huit emplois dans le monde de la
transformation dans le monde plus on est
tourné en particulier vers l'élevage
plus la transformation et donc l'emploi
est conséquent fait comment je m'en
donne envie dans un métier aussi
difficile en donnant vie en
je suis convaincu que des tas de jeunes
peuvent être attirés par l'agriculture
la meilleure franchement la meilleure
preuve
agricole il s'installe chacun ses
problèmes chacun aider les agriculteurs
parfois eux mêmes se plaignent et sont
surpris que leurs enfants de leur
succèdent par un moment donné vous poser
aussi des questions dans le monde
agricole
le monde agricole permet de se réaliser
de faire des choses ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de constater qu'elle
pensait que pour une installation
la plupart vont au bout de leur carrière
c'est pas du tout ce qui se passe dans
le monde du commerce ou les choses
s'arrêtent au bout de trois quatre ans
ça veut dire qu'il ya des choses
positives
le vrai sujet c'est que notre société
doit savoir ce qu'elle veut de son
agriculture
est-ce qu'on abandonne l'alimentation
cet arbre gigantesque aux américains et
aux russes aux australiens aux
sud-américains cessa sujet si on
abandonne pas si l'europe veut une
politique elle change de nature
elle change l'agriculteur idéal pour un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes
urbain c'est un petit agriculteurs
pauvres qui lui plus ou moins dans la
misère et qui vend au marché du coin
c'est pas ça l'agriculture où c'est ça
peut-être statistiquement etc existent
c'est très bien c'est aussi autre chose
ces deux sur touche plus de la moitié de
nos céréales sont exportés chez moi dans
dans dans le département où je vis la
plupart des ddd port que nous produisons
sont transformés sur place mais sont
consommés dans la france entière va dans
le repentant là vous nous parler
d'économie de la limite culture
française ouverte sur le monde mais ça
reste une vie de labeur et là je me suis
ouverte labeur et ses pédales fois
reconnu c'est pour ça qu'il faut cesser
d'attaquer des gens qui travaillent qui
sont respectueux des règles qui sont
honnêtes qui essaie de progresser dont
la vie est une vie de transformation ont
des glaces aussi des doigts se
transformer si une population sin
profession qui a accepté cette évolution
les évolutions diverses et variées c'est
le monde agricole dont arrêtons d
attaquer l'un des sujets majeurs et ça
ça dépend de nos enchères jean baptiste
ça dépend de du législateur c'est de
donner des signes pour lutter contre la
grippe à chinon puis au tableau
alimentaire c'était pas un problème dans
les années 80-90 à peu leur devenir
demain ou après demain avec la
diminution du risque pour passer tous
les grands argentiers en venir je
voudrais qu'on entende rodolphe marconi
parce que il a suivi pendant quatre mois
c'est ça jour et nuit un homme qui
s'appelle cyril on le voit très bien
dans le film c'est un franchement c'est
un métier qui donne pas envie d'y
travailler 7 jours sur 7 70 heures par
semaine sans vacances vous n'avez
finalement pas de vie vous allez nous
raconter pourquoi vous avez voulu
tourner cette villa comment vous allez
rencontrer cyril mais d'abord un extrait
de la bande annonce tout de suite
[Musique]
voilà cyril du lait du beurre des dettes
ça sort mercredi prochain en salles
comment comment ça s'est passé cette
rencontre l envie de filmer ce jeune
agriculteur improbable je suis sur une
plage
je vais me baigner tous les jours depuis
quatre jours je vois un garçon cas les
pieds dans l'eau qui regardent la mer
toute la journée qui se baignent pas et
un matin je sors de l'eau il est à deux
mètres de moi donc je vais je suis dit
mais comme ça ni bonjour ni un jeu dit
mais tu devrais y aller pas froide et il
me dit je sais pas nager
du coup je dis ah bon tu es en vacances
serrano et là je comprends qu'il est
c'est la première fois de sa vie qui
part en vacances en fait qu'il n'avait
jamais vu la mer et qui les agriculteurs
laitiers en auvergne un chien comme je
vais dire contrairement à vous
l'agriculture c'est aussi ça c'est pas
que ça mais c'est aussi ça parfois et et
là je je prend son téléphone et six mois
après je l'appelle je dis est ce que je
peux venir te filmer et je mets les
pieds dans un endroit que je n'imaginais
pas enfin je n'avais aucune idée de ce
que j'allais visa vous avez une
expérience ici puisque j'ai deux amis
agriculteurs en charente maritime
1 quelle vie vous découvrez au quotidien
lever 6 heures du matin c'est aussi ça
non parce qu'il ya encore aussi deux
petits dés de petites exploitations qui
sont perdus un peu qui sont reculés il
est à 40 minutes deux tiers mais
vraiment dans l'auvergne profonde est
pas non plus une métropole vivante s est
déjà tiers n'est pas là et c'est
quelqu'un qui en fait pour prendre la
succession plus ou moins de sa maman
c'est vraiment avait des étables enfin
une petite ferme quoi lui il a dû
évidemment construire un bâtiment enfin
c'est un peu le truc classique
c'est-à-dire emprunt bâtiment tout roule
jusqu'au moment où il ya deux étés de
sécheresse l'un après l'autre et là
évidemment qui dit pas spirale de la
dette pas d'herbe pas de l'ehpad les pas
d'argent donc pas de foin l'hiver non
plus et on peut pas les crédits à la
banque
voilà et est ensuite huit vaches qui
meurent elles à ce qui ce qui frappe
aussi dans le film c'est son extrême
solitude celle là c'est le mot principal
un sujet ça c'est le mot principal parce
que enfin moi le suicide des
agriculteurs enfin je suis c'est une
réalité c'est quand même la profession
il ya là plus de plus grand nombre de
suicides par jour et il repose bien sûr
sur des détresses économique sur des
problèmes économiques mais pas seulement
- les derniers qui a eu en cause hélas
repose sur des exploitations qui est
économiquement tenait encore la route
mais qui psychologiquement des gens qui
ont craqué quoi parce que parce
qu'effectivement ils n'ont pas de vie
parce qu'effectivement ils peuvent pas
partir en vacances parce qu'ils ont
assez peu de week-end après voilà c'est
pas non plus la totalité mais
effectivement la course à
l'agrandissement a fait que aujourd'hui
il ya de moins en moins de main d'oeuvre
sur les exploitations il ya de plus en
plus de boulot et et au bout d'un moment
si les gens n'arrivent pas à employer de
la main d'oeuvre ou alors il se retrouve
tout seul
et dans le cas de cyril c'est important
que vous disiez ça parce que je pense
aussi que je parlais du contexte tout à
l'heure parce que c'est un contexte
particulier il ya des agriculteurs qui
le soir entre ont leurs femmes ont un
bisou un câlin un repas peuvent parler
échanger partager les emmerdes aussi
quand vous vous prenez tout tout seul
c'est encore plus difficile
comment il il en parle de cette ville à
cette vie de sacrifice est ce qui vient
quand même une place pour la passion
parce que on se dit qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on continue mais blizzard envisagent
en fait au début du film j'adore quand
il raconte quand il était petit qu'avant
l'école il aller traire les vaches et
après l'école il
c'était sa vie quand même c'était
c'était une vraie passion pour lui et je
crois que le plus difficile c'était pas
d'accepter les chèques mais c'était de
se dire que sa passion il n'avait pas pu
il n'a pas pu aller au bout
en fait voilà pue ça n'a pas marché quoi
cette crise des vocations comment on
fait c'est vrai passionné et même si
aujourd'hui et d'élevage économiquement
marche mal tous les lycées agricoles les
filières d'élevage sont quasiment plein
dans quasiment tous les lycées agricoles
c'est ça qui est surprenante et autant
dans d'autres filières c'est pas le cas
au temps des filières d'élevage parce
que effectivement l'attachement à ses
animaux et l'attachement aux vaches
quand on les a connus depuis tout petit
comme ça peut être mon cas moi j'ai fait
une formation d'ingénieur j'ai travaillé
mais je suis quand même j'ai quand même
fini par revenir par passion pas part
intérêt par l'appétit du gain quoi parce
que c'est très bien que j'étais je
gagnais certainement beaucoup plus quand
j'étais sa vas y que quand je suis
agriculteur mais c'est une vraie passion
c'est quelque chose qu'on a dans les
tripes écart qui prend aux tripes
la passion et puis il ya aussi les
moyens pour vivre c'est une question
quand on regarde les chiffres c'est
c'est effrayant 1 21 % des agriculteurs
travaillent 70 heures par semaine 34 %
-34% c'est la baisse du nombre
d'agriculteurs installés entre 96 et
2017 un tiers des exploitants on l'a dit
on plus de 55 ans donc c'est vraiment
une
une profession vieillissante qu'est ce
qu'on fait quelques outils 1
cette loi sur sur les revenus la partage
le partage de la valeur qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour faire en sorte qu'ils gagnent
mieux
oui la loi n'a pas un a pas marché il
faudrait que l'ue se sont sont bien que
n'importe où pas pour vous peut y
revenir mais pas par contre ce qui
compte c'est la faute aux distributeurs
pour comprendre elle marche mamani
footballeur fait reconstituer plus
compliqué l'un des sujets c'est que
quand vie c'est vrai de manière isolée
ces sites à des sujets de l'agriculture
la solitude le regard que les autres
portent sur vous même ou sur votre
profession compte beaucoup et c'est vrai
que ce regard était très positif je
crois qu'il leur est aux tréfonds de
l'opinion mais il y a tout une cabale
qui est entretenue contre le monde
agricole alors ce sont des gens qui
travaillent qui est au delà de
l'accaparement dans les médias
meanstream un peu quand même
et puis l'autre élément c'est que on est
dans une attitude doctrine études un peu
un peu surprenante
tout le monde a une opinion sur la
composition de l'équipe de france de
foot puis maintenant tout le monde a une
opinion sur ce qu'on doit faire dans les
champs on n'est pas du métier on ne sait
pas on doive on n'a pas les tenants et
les aboutissants on passe on voit qu'on
devienne un enjeu de chacun d'entre nous
c'est plutôt oui mais moi je dis que
c'est un métier c'est une technique
ce sont des compétences des compétences
qui sont liées au monde agricole mais
qui sont liées aussi à tout en un
environnement autour du monde indique
enfin à jouer aussi peu d'interrogations
et sont aujourd'hui
à dénicher des réunions en préfecture
qui se veulent des réunions officielles
ou les retraités des postes en plus de
choses à dire sur l'agriculture que les
agriculteurs entendaient vaporisant même
que la profession' arrive dans ces
métiers et dont danser leurs venues
danser leurs revenus
c'est c'est pas c'est pas un intérêt
momentanée sais c'est sa vie c'est son
patrimoine c'est ce qu'il veut
transmettre à ses enfants
il a quand même quelque chose à dire et
on doit respecter sa parole n'empêche
que dans le film de rodolphe marconi
sélect qui crée pas des revenus alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour qu'enfin les
agriculteurs dans ce pays puisse gagner
dignement leur vie
d'abord je pense qu'il faut comprendre
qu'il ya plein d'agriculture différentes
en france et que le ce jeune homme qui
souffre dans un endroit isolé par
exemple le bio le passage au bio ça peut
lui permettre de valoriser un tout petit
cheptel
mais sauf qu'il n'est pas en péril robin
donc il faut trouve qu'il faut qu'ils
trouvent des filières c'est difficile
c'est pour ça que le bo peut permettre
de valoriser des milieux difficiles
parce que on va vendre beaucoup plus
cher c'est pas possible pour tout le
monde pour l'instant c'est là d'ailleurs
non c'est la première excuse moi je
répondrais oui
non c'est la première chose naïvement
puisque moi je j'ai fait le film parce
que je les rencontre et ne le connaissez
pas la vie culturelle
c'est la première chose que je lui ai
dit je dis mais pourquoi vaste plan bio
oui
et qu'est ce qu'il a dit eh bien il m'a
dit que passer en bio ça voulait dire
beaucoup de frais quoi c'est bien voilà
alors c'est ça alors c'est là que
raccompagner les agréments tout à fait
parce que les gens s'illusionne
aujourd'hui nous nous laisse les urbains
on pense que le bio va résoudre tous les
problèmes
en réalité en bio c'est compliqué on
produit peut il faut vendre beaucoup
plus cher on a des contraintes aussi et
donc l'idée qu' en généralisant le bio
on va résoudre le problème de
l'agriculture
c'est une fausse bonne idée d'abord
parce qu'on a besoin d'une agriculture
compétitive on a besoin d'une
agriculture qui puisse exporter à nos
portes on a des zones structurellement
déficitaires les côtes d'armor la grande
bretagne c'est un pays qui a besoin
d'importer de la nourriture d'ailleurs
on est très inquiet sur le break 6 mais
ce que je voudrais dire quand même
servir sur l'idée de cette vision un peu
misérabiliste de cette profession
parce que j'étais récemment en bourgogne
franche comté où les agriculteurs les
jeunes agriculteurs ont créé le
mouvement de la grille loving ils ont
dit mais nous on a on n'en veut plus
nous on est fiers on est heureux d'être
agriculteur on maîtrise des techniques
de ce qu'on appelle les outils d aide à
la décision c'est-à-dire de la
cartographie satellitaires des robots
des dons qu'il y a dans l'agriculture ce
qu'on appelle les agriculteurs c'est à
dire des gens qui sont vraiment
résolument engagé dans la troisième
révolution transforma la grille tout est
associé kiwi la communication peut aimer
ça ne remplacera jamais le bon sens
paysan c'est à dire que ces gens et la
machine va jamais on a besoin d'agrumes
butin dans l'est quand j entends bien
mais alors mon dos et ça suffira pour
reparler des installations dans des
installations
vous avez des femmes vous avez des gens
qui sont ce qu'on appelle leur cadre
c'est-à-dire qui viennent brett
l'agriculture et qui ont envie d'être
agricole à green agriculteurs vous avez
des gens qui reprennent aussi bien sûr
d'être à la boudègue rêver à un monde en
mutation mon nom avec un avenir possible
mon petit maintenant serait un voûte ma
question c'est tout simple on comprend
que le bio c'est compliqué ça coûte cher
il faut accompagner il faut des sous
vous les mettez ce gouvernement les mais
ça c'est la politique agricole commune
elles sont en cours il ya deux jours
cruciaux là en ce moment le président la
république et au conseil de l'europe il
va négocier le budget global de l'europe
qui va impacter le budget de la pac il
faut que ce constant mais au-delà de ça
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il
faut que l'agriculture retrouve une des
principales vertus qui a fait sa force
pendant des centaines d'années à savoir
la solidarité
aujourd'hui on a en face des
agriculteurs des gros groupes
industriels en agroalimentaire que 600
trains vendus et quatre centrales
d'achat mais les deux on a les deux si
on n'arrive pas à s'organiser au niveau
de la profession en organisation de
producteurs en association
d'organisations de producteurs ça a été
partiellement fait en production les
vous êtes en tradition c'est fou le
monde agricole n'arrive pas à
s'organiser face à des distributeurs ou
les centres et douars pourquoi c'est ce
que sont plus solides est parce que les
agriculteurs font des intérêts des
agriculteurs on leur a demandé de plus
produire donc plutôt plus produire il a
fallu qu'ils diminuent les charges il a
fallu qui s'agrandissent qu'ils
agrandissent et exploitation et ça ça
s'est fait au détriment du nombre
d'agriculteurs qui a diminué dans les
villages aujourd'hui moi dans mon
village il y avait cet agriculteur et un
à-pic deux on est plus que deux
agriculteurs aujourd'hui dans lui
âge et le problème c'est que ça s'est
fait au détriment de la solidarité
permettent des amortissements
d'exploitation moins d'agressions
on arrive au fond c'est quelqu'un parce
que sonné au delà de 100 villages par
par unité de main-d'oeuvre c'est-à-dire
par agriculteur c'est c'est plus
possible dans l'élevage autant dans les
grandes cultures on peut encore avec
l'outillage et la mecque et la
mécanisation agrandir les surfaces dans
l'élevage quand vous avez plus de 100
villages par tête de pipe
vous ne pouvez plus vous à grandir parce
que vous avez des résultats techniques
qui décroissent un vêlage il faut
quasiment tout le temps être là au moins
à surveiller si c'est pas pour
interpeller tous exploités non non c'est
pas non c'est pas petit ccc oui de
retrouver ddd compétence technico
économiques y sont cohérentes avec des
exploitations qu'on retrouve certaines
bases de l'agronomie qu on a oublié au
détriment on va dire de la production à
outrance et surtout qu'on retrouve la
solidarité du monde paysan qui fait qu'
on essaie d'aider le voisin c'est pas on
n'attend pas juste qui coule pour lui
racheter son exploitation voilà ce que
furent vos solutions
les agriculteurs une capacité pour
s'organiser ils l'ont démontré
il entraîne un triplé ont démontré dans
les années 60-70 si l'on mange chez moi
c'est raphaël un mois un peu technique
mais c'est l'ailé des gens extrêmement
pointue dans le domaine du légume du
fruit qui exporte près téléphérique
c'est donc ils ont besoin de personne
pour s'organiser nous notre travail en
tant que législateur c'est de les
accompagner
oui c'est pas de les organiser mais
c'est ça dégueulasse était une boîte à
outils c c'est ce serait d'éviter les
concentrations dans la grande
distribution
oui mais elles sont déjà elles sont déjà
lourd pour pour la distribution il
aurait fallu les empêcher les gens sont
déjà d'accord va pas 10 ou d'une
entreprise demain vous le savez bien
et loi anti cartel ce existants donc ça
ça c'est une rolls et faire une
entreprise il faut également que nous
sachions dire et dénoncer ceux qui font
profession d'attaquer le monde agricole
j'ai eu des intrusions avec en plus un
collègue député qui rentrait france a
soumises qui rendent tout ça pour
prendre des films qui dont le but est de
discréditer de discréditer d'alerté mais
de fait de discréditer la femme quand on
voit les belles de 114,2 discret
d'entrer chez les gens aujourd'hui de
fait il ne se passe rien il n'y a pas de
suite judiciaire de ce tout cela est ce
normal
le propre de la responsabilité publique
c'est déjà de protéger celui qui
travaille honnêtement en respectant des
règles compliquées qui essaient face à
une concurrence très redoutable la
concurrence les allemandes
elle est espagnole et d'un bordel et en
plus maintenant et va devenir
extra-européenne puisqu'on a passé un
accord absolu avec le canada non mais
c'est un aujourd'hui dès le mois d'août
a française c'est comment on charge nos
agriculteurs d'exigence sociale j'ai
versé et on va multiplier des
importations venant de produits qui ne
respectent rien de tout ça non il faut
arrêter d schizophrénique séquence
marconnet qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit du
politique
votre agriculteurs série laisse qui est
ce qu'il attend encore des solutions
ce qu'il regarde par exemple les
négociation sur la politique agricole
commune sur sur ces enjeux là je crois
qu'il est une sorte de résignation
au moment où je suis arrivé pour le pour
le film et je pensais rester trois
semaines m'ont finalement je suis resté
quatre mois
mais le redressement judiciaire était
déjà en route donc de toutes façons ces
journées c'était quoi c'était d'essayer
de pas tomber avant le soir quoi et puis
et puis de sauver les meubles
il était plus dans cette
dans cette recherche comme ça dans cette
danse est question en fait plus du tout
pensé qu'il va arrêter
oui alors bon je peux pas raconter le
film et oui c'est ses volumes ccc
l'histoire par un renoncement
bon on va on va passer pour terminer ce
débat à cet enjeu qui se joue à
bruxelles donc la négociation de la
politique agricole commune les
britanniques sont partis le budget va
diminuer cette cruciale et la copie pour
l'instant sur la table des 27 ne
satisfait pas la france écoutez emmanuel
macron à son arrivée au sommet nous nous
battrons pour améliorer encore la
proposition qui a été faite
la proposition a permis une des
premières améliorations et je m'en
félicite
nous n'y sommes encore pas nous ne
sommes pas au rendez vous de ce que nous
souhaitons pour notre politique agricole
commune et je souhaite que les
prochaines heures et les prochains jours
nous permettent d'améliorer la copie
c'est indispensable pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire c'est aussi
indispensable pour avoir une agriculture
qui permettent l'alimentation de qualité
et la transition climatique que nous
défendons si les brunelles il écrit
bande très bien les cruciales cet enjeu
là parce que aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs certains d'entre eux vivent
à cent pour cent du soutien de la pac
c'est un vrai c'est un certain d'entre
eux pas tous la pac et lorient notamment
oui mais mais oui il la france se bat
depuis le début d'ailleurs la première
proposition de la commission européenne
c'est grâce à la france qu'elle a été
rejetée parce qu'elle lll induisent et à
une baisse de 18% du budget de la
politique agricole commune donc céder la
politique agricole commune c'est le
résultat de la volonté française qu'on a
fait partager à nos amis européens
il faut une détermination il faut que je
sois très fort quelle conséquence il
faut utiliser le budget c'est très
important de baisse perd politique et
c'est pas simplement un sujet français c
est ce que oui ou non on abandonne tout
ça aux autres et quand on insiste sur
les niches et toutes ces choses
on collabore un peu à cette logique de
nos concurrents
c'est à dire nous ne nous limitons riom
à deux petits chiens les niches alès que
jamais en lice le bio on n'a pas le
droit de se limiter à faire et il faut
le faire peur que nous soyons présents
sur la production laitière sur la
production céréalière sous la plume de
jean de viande il faut jamais oublier
il faut jamais oublier que la plupart de
nos compatriotes sont des gens modestes
la question de la fraude et la france se
bat depuis deux ans et demi pour pour
que le ce budget de la pac soit à la
hauteur des ambitions de l'europe à
savoir d'abord l'autonomie alimentaire
et après la transition mais d'abord
l'autonomie alimentaire bien sûr je ne
veux pas remettre une
allez me disais je l'appel à la
solidarité européenne sur cette question
importante pour tenir face aux chinois
aux riffs me doutais parce que vous
veniez dira juste avant parfaite nos
principale concurrent était justement
européen donc s'entendre avec des gens
qui sait vous savez la guerre
aujourd'hui c'est de ça se passe au
niveau du présent dans le public comme
c'est s'est passé autrefois au niveau du
général de gaulle jacques chirac et
autres c'est une détermination et une
volonté ce n'est pas un sujet annexe
ce n'est pas un sujet qui concerne
uniquement 2 % de la population
française c'est un sujet qui concerne la
place de la france en aura quatre
sociales et environnementales au niveau
agricole au niveau européen et que les
actes et les adducteurs besoin d'une
vraie direction de savoir où ils vont
sommets européens et les annonces sans
doute dans deux jours merci à tous
rodolphe marconi aller voir ce
documentaire cyril agriculteurs 30 ans
des bêtes du lait allez le voir
merci à vous pour rester avec 12 sylvie
brunel plessisville suisse hugues dubeau
plus au deuxième parc vous allez avoir
du temps que vous la compagnie
américaine avait encore rien américaine
vous passionne j'en suis sûr on va
accueillir tout de suite françois
durpaire pour sa chronique qui veut
prendre sa place tout de suite
immersion
[Musique]
allez on est en direct
on a bon s'installe où se côtoient va
continuer à débattre agriculture sur ce
plateau ses bazars c'est un peu comme si
les démocrates et un peu on peut le dire
on peut le dire françois il y en a qui
rentrait dans la course et l'a mis il a
pris son temps parce qu'il voulait pas
participer au départ la bri les
primaires j'ai nommé michael bloomberg
multimilliardaire ancien maire de new
york il a donc participé hier soir à son
premier débat à las vegas est ce que
vous savez ce qui se passe à las vegas
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche non
c'est toute l'amérique le cctld wider
d'un côté furie de l'autre c'est le
combat de boxe des poids lourds aux
états unis et la nuit dernière à
quelques mètres de là il y avait un
autre combat de boxe
à ma droite donc michael bloomberg
l'homme qui valait 50 7 milliards il en
a déjà dépensé 300 millions rien que
dans la campagne même 400 millions selon
certains chiffres et à ma gauche tout
gauche tout gauche ou de gauche le
favori bernie sanders camatte en une
avance à deux chiffres il est à 32 % et
ça donne ça vous savez quoi monsieur
bloomberg
ce n'est pas vous qui avez gagné tout
cet argent peut-être que vos
travailleurs aussi ont joué un certain
rôle est il est important que les
travailleurs soient aussi en mesure de
partager les bénéfices
nous avons beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent tous les jours et qui ne se
sentent pas bien dans leur travail je ne
vois pas comment donald trump pourrait
se faire réélire plus facilement en
écoutant cette conversation
c'est ridicule nous n'allons pas jeter
le capitalisme nous avons essayé
d'autres pays ont essayé ça ça
s'appelait le communisme et ça n'a pas
marché
c'est rigolo de les bars lever la main
voyez comment c'est comme l école aux
états unis c'est pas 50 nuance et pas de
nuances de bleu bleu c'est la couleur
démocrate voyez bien qu'on est là
complètement dans des univers différents
d'un côté le plus capitaliste des
capitalistes la 9e fortune du monde plus
capitaliste que trump
oui en tout cas plus libérale il n'est
pas dans le patriotisme économique
et puis de l'autre côté quelqu'un qu'on
qualifie de communistes on les imagine
mal voté l'un pour l'autre dans quelques
semaines alors les images elles sont pas
être à du spa ce qui s'est passé le
combat c'était un chaos le chaos
c'est le chaos de bloomberg il est
apparu rouillé dans la presse américaine
tout le monde lui tapent dessus
aujourd'hui la pas réussi à se défendre
savez les accusations de misogynie des
accusations de racisme
il était vraiment pas bon du tout la
nuit dernière alors il pourra se
consoler en se disant que il ya moins
d'américains qui ont regardé le débat
que d'américains qui regarde ses potes
ces spots publicitaires qui pourra se
consoler en disant qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui se disent notamment
dans l'establishment qu'il est le seul
homme à pouvoir et bien pouvoir battre
trump et surtout ses millions et on
écoute ce qui va dire là dessus je ne
peux pas parler au nom de tous les
milliardaires
tout ce que je sais c'est que j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance que j'ai gagné
beaucoup d'argent et que je donne tout
pour vendre ce pays meilleur une bonne
partie de cet argent va aussi au parti
démocrate
est-ce que c'est trop et ce que vous
avez gagné trop d'argent et sous-sols
obscène auriez vous dû gagner autant
d'argent
gas oui j'ai travaillé très dur pour
cela et je le donne ça passe aux pages
donne ça passe quand même auprès de
certains parce que effectivement c'est
son atout l'argent il peut dépenser des
millions des millions de spots contre
donald trump et ceux qui n'aiment pas
bloomberg aime quand même les dollars
contre jonathan dire qu'il est beaucoup
beaucoup plus risquées des banques aux
plus riches et à imaginer plus de 50
milliards 57 milliards il a d'autres
atouts l'expérience 12 ans maire de new
york new york c'est l'économie de la
corée du sud pour se faire une idée
et puis et puis il a surtout sa posture
politique on ne change pas une économie
qui gagne il ya beaucoup d'américains
qui vont se dire bon nous on veut bien
être démocrate mais enfin on est au
milieu de la phase de croissance au
québec sont les allemands malgré la
maintenant on pense qu'il a la posture
économique mais ya quand même une très
grosse faiblesse
c'est ce qu'a dit notamment l'un de ses
opposants la nuit dernière qui a dit
mais il est très très bien il pourrait
vraiment gagner une primaire mais pas la
primaire démocrate à primaires
républicaines il a commencé vers de new
york
il était républicain et là
malheureusement pour lui bat a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens vos belles et les noirs
ne vote pas pour lui les femmes ne vont
pas voter pour lui et le fameuse
ouvriers blancs qu'il faut reconquérir
en 2020 et ce qui va voter bloomberg
on a l'impression que c'est vraiment le
candidat qui va peut-être avoir des
chances lors de l'élection générale mais
avant il ya la primaire démocrate
d'élections primaires et ça ça sera
beaucoup plus homme qui n'était pas
forcément dans le bon camp elle vous
passionne 7 cette campagne massive et
brunel elle me passionne et je pense que
les américains n'ont pas du tout le
problème que nous avons nous vis-à-vis
de l'argent sert pour aucun candidat
soit riche c'est la preuve qu'il a été
brillant qu'il a été doux et les
américains ont le culte de l'argent chez
nous c'est honteux
mais voilà donc ce n'est pas un handicap
du tout pour lui des mets riches a suffi
non bien sûr ça ne suffit pas surtout
comme on l'a vu il n'avait pas parlé
aussi des attaques de la candidate
féminine qui la met des cent du couple
un milliardaire un milliardaire qui dit
que les femmes sont grosses qui dit que
ce sont des lesbiennes à tête de cheval
c'est qui c'est qui c'est qui donald
trump
non c'est michael bloomberg attendre il
est déjà hors course on verra une
voiture pas sûr parce que toute façon
c'est enfin je pense vous êtes d'accord
avec moi on sait que 30 mètres il de
toute façon plus en être sûr o o étant
donnée la bagarre l'autodestruction en
face de lui
lui n'a pas de au sein du coc sans doute
au sein du corps républicain qui est sûr
c'est qu'une boîte à idées pour donald
trump oui si rare
regardez ce qu'a dit sanders den bakker
humeur regardez ce qu'a dit de l'
inverse
oui c'est vrai que ça ça pose vraiment
la question de ces primaires on sait
bien en france aussi qu'on s'interroge
sur le rôle des primaires efficacité des
accès avec les primaires c'est comme une
machine à détruire après il faut s'unir
mais une fois qu'on a bien détruit c'est
difficile quand matt est impossible de
remettre en cause sa aux états unis les
primaires c'est la pub mais les
séquences étant s'américanise et on n'a
pas vrai et on n'a pas des codes
américain c'est très difficile
d'importer en france on l'a vu les
primaires normalement les primaires
c'est fait pour qu'ils aient des
primaires des deux côtés et là il ya une
égalité mais quand le président est en
place et que de l'autre côté il ya une
primaire belle lui compte les coûts et
c'est pour ça que depuis 2009 112 il ya
que trois présidents compas éthérée la
prochaine étape c'est quoi la prochaine
étape c'est le vous ne suivez pas meriam
c'est ce week end le match de boxe
pendant le match de boxe il y aura
évidemment un autre match très attendu
non non il ya un autre bain il ya le
samedi prochain le nevada donc c'est
important dans le nevada c'est important
pour byron cib hayden père dans le
nevada là on va voir annoncer la semaine
prochaine je viendrai en noir pour
malades et sanders il est en tête dans
le nevada et si je vous donne déjà le
titre de la presse américaine de
dimanche si sanders gagne ça sera
qu'est-ce que sanders peut être battu on
va voir ça merci cette écurie veut bien
passionnant abc françois durpaire
il est pas sûr il nous fait vivre cette
campagne sur lcp chaque semaine merci
françois
allez on va parler à présente ce débat
parlementaire vous le savez qu'il tourne
au fiasco le mot n'est pas trop la
réforme des retraites
vous le savez ressemble à une guerre de
tranchées depuis trois jours maintenant
dans l'hémicycle alors avant de revenir
dans le détail sur les différents points
de blocage et derniers rebondissements
regardez en images ce que ça donne dans
l'hémicycle rappel au règlement
interruption séance invectives elsa
monde un gamin nous a sélectionné pour
les plus belles passes d'armes si l'on
peut dire de cette dernière 24 regardez
à la place d'un débat sur la réforme des
retraites
une foire d'empoigné devriez vous calmer
on vous inquiétez pas je suis très calme
nous sommes entrés en résistance
ici aussi dans l'hémicycle je peux à
peine de trier vous imposer le monologue
et le monologue stature est ce que vous
remettez en cause la présidence
je viens de faire injurier publiquement
jouer savoir ce qu'il ya des vies nous
avons ici menaces insultes
un débat indigne ne vociférer pas en
attaque ad hominem ou plus exactement
atx et mini jeux ne l'est pas nommé
puisque je ne sais même pas comment elle
s'appelle l'accessoire indispensable des
acteurs de l'opposition c'est ce livre
rouge et bleu le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale
brandie comme un carton jaune pour
interrompre les débats
vous avez confondu sur quels fondements
sur le fond demain de londres sur le
fondement de l'erreur vous venez de
commettre
monsieur le président vous avez confondu
gelleri 1,4 et l'alinéa 5
rim vingtaine de suspension de séance la
séance donc suspendu pour 15 minutes
comme autant d'entracte un spectacle qui
s'éternise la séance suspendue
suspension de séance pour cinq minutes
la séance suspendus pour cinq et qui
risque bien d'épuiser ses acteurs et ses
spectateurs
bonsoir dominique rousseau bonjour et
merci d'être sur lcp avec nous vous êtes
constitutionnaliste professeur à
l'université panthéon sorbonne
stéphanie des pierres merci de
m'accompagner ce soir c'est vous qui
suivez entre autres à la rédaction de
lcp
cette réforme des retraites et tous ces
débats houleux
je commence avec vous on comprend dans
le sujet d'elsa mandingue avec cette
guerre de tranchées
elle s'est cristallisée sur la question
des amendements identiques on l'a vu
avec des divergences d'interprétation
sur ce document que chaque député brandi
désormais quand on est dans l'opposition
surtout un haut et fort c'est le
règlement rouge et bleu le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale a ou en étant ce
soir et est-ce qu'il ya encore une
chance de sortir par le haut de ce débat
eh bien écoutez face à la bronca richard
ferrand a fait marcher
hier aujourd'hui il renonce à la règle
qui voulait faire appliquer sur un
certain type d'amendements identiques
hier il voulait faire tomber en série d
amendements identiques déposés en
différents endroits du texte cela aurait
pu faire sauter un millier d'amendements
communiste alors aujourd'hui il a changé
d'avis conséquence up les 1184
amendements en question sont donc
finalement réintroduit dans la
discussion
la gauche crie victoire pourquoi le
président de l'assemblée at-il fait
volte-face et bien parce qu'il craint le
conseil constitutionnel et explique la
gauche et notamment le parti socialiste
qui a sorti ce matin toute une série
d'arguments juridiques pour contrer
richard ferrand si le président avait
était sûr de son bon droit il ne serait
pas revenu sur cette question dès le nom
main assure une député de droite marie
christine dalloz
le président de l'assemblée lui explique
que c'est pour ne pas donner de prétexte
à l'obstruction ce qui se jouait
désormais myriam pour la majorité ces
décès la bataille de l'opinion puisque
la république en marche cherche à
montrer aux français que s'il n'y a pas
de débat de fond c'est à cause donc de
l'opposition donc on a compris que ça
avance extrêmement lentement c'est une
course de lenteur et la question au fond
c'est plus 6 49 3 va être dégainée mais
quand un proche au camp puisque on
avance tout doucement on est toujours à
l'article 1er je vous rappelle qu'il y
en a 65 et ce après quatre jours de
discussions en début d'après midi
richard faire on a pu donc que constater
l'enlisement le débat va très très
doucement vitesse nous en comptons
d'amendements ici 22 amendements à leur
écoute et richard ferrand à ce rythme
mais le 640 trois heures de séances
seront nécessaires pour terminer la
seule loi ordinaire soit si l'assemblée
siège du lundi au dimanche soir
en respectant les heures réglementaires
nos séances 150 jours de séance 150
jours donc l'accélération c'est pas pour
maintenant puisque la france est soumise
et les communistes ont une nouvelle
stratégie en se veut lire l'assemblée
avec des milliers de sous-amendements
ans qu'ils ont ici a déjà dans le même
de centaines de vidéos c'est ça oui mais
bleu chiffres il ya eu un petit bug sur
le chiffre on était parti dans des
centaines de milliers d'amendements on
est redescendu
petit peu oui la conclusion c'est qu'il
y à déjà plus d'amendements qu'au début
du texte lundi la majorité parle de
sabotage et elle cherche toujours la
parade mais son succès pour le moment
alors vous le disiez y aura-t-il un 49 3
et il n'y a plus vraiment de doute
aujourd'hui la question par contre c'est
plutôt qu'en maintenant la semaine
prochaine juste avant les municipales et
l'autre question c'est comment faire
accepter le 49-3 à la majorité parce
qu'en fait une frange des députés la
république en marche ne veut pas se
faire confisquer le débat mois les
municipales je m'en cogne on a le temps
le temps et de les vendre a dit
longtemps fait le faux c'est ça une
commissaires aux finances la réforme des
retraites en fait vous l'avez compris
est devenu une course d'endurance mais à
la vitesse de l'escargot excellent je
comprends tout à dominique rousseau
sincère qui ce qui se passe dans
l'hémicycle ben écoutez spectacle ne
sert pas la démocratie
ça ne sert pas la démocratie dans la
mesure où le parlement est fait pour
délibérer le parlement est fait pour
discuter des textes pour les modifier
les amendes et à partir d'un principe
constitutionnel qui est clair et qui est
rappelé régulièrement par le conseil
constitutionnel
les débats doivent être clair et serein
bon là actuellement ils sont ni claires
ni serein
le risque existe là je ma question porte
sur la constitution le ce texte le
risque d'une censure de la procédure
actuelle engagé pour le vote de la loi
sur la réforme des retraites ne me
paraît pas grand dans la mesure où le
conseil constitutionnel a à plusieurs
reprises indiqué que l' usage abusif de
droit d'amendement justifiait lusage du
droit de résister à cette obstruction en
faisant tomber les amendements par
exemple il ya un usage médias les textes
par exemple le le
le règlement permet aux au président de
limiter le droit de parole pour des
amendements à objets identiques et
défendu par des parlementaires
appartenant au même groupe
ouais bon pour l'instant je crois qu'il
ne l'a pas il ne l'a pas encore utilisé
et le conseil constitutionnel a validé
cette possibilité de limiter le temps de
parole sous réserve
enfin à condition plus exactement à
condition que se tenait cet amendement
soit utilisée de manière abusive et pour
ralentir les débats comprend ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'au fond ce nouveau
règlement de l'assemblée nationale qui a
été adopté contre l'opposition 2008 une
entrée en matière a été très très
regardée par le conseil constitutionnel
on peut pas faire changer les règles du
jeu comme ça entre soi entre députés à
l'assemblée sans aucun contrôle non mais
le conseil constitutionnel a validé le
droit pour le président de deux séances
de limiter le temps de parole de limites
et même la parole d'un député si
l'amendement a le même objet et si il
est défendu par les députés d'un même
vrai donc ça c'est constitutionnel
et si vous voulez là encore une fois il
ya un principe qui est celui de la
clarté de la sérénité le la chose est un
peu un peu technique
c'est un peu bizarre c'est à dire que le
on voit bien aujourd'hui que
l'opposition
veut empêcher le vote de la loi alors
c'est sûr elle n'y arrivera pas eu une
majorité au parlement soit par le 49-3
soit par un art et qu'on ait oublié qui
est le 44 l'article 44 votes bloqués qui
ne diminue pas le temps des débats mais
qui bloque comme bloquée qui bloque le
texte sur la rédaction voulue par le
gouvernement crée pas de celle qu
emmanuel macron soit obligée avec
edouard philippe de dégainer 49,3 il
faut rappeler qu'il en avait été victime
lui-même alors sur les bancs du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
voudraient vous montrer une séquence
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de cette
obstruction systématique des insoumis
qu'il assume pleinement
mais franchement c'est pas très nouveau
regardé ce qui se passait en 2010
c'était la précédente réforme des
retraites elle était c'est la saignée
françois fillon je ne laisserai pas au
travers de petites manoeuvres
l'obstruction qui est paralysante et
dévalorisante pour notre parlement se
réinstaller prévisions
démission démission quelle honte quand
la vente
président de l'assemblée nationale a
violé le règlement aura violé les droits
des députés phonie là pourquoi on débat
86 est ce que les gens dans la rue qui
étaient dans la rue hier savent que ici
même le gouvernement est en train de
manoeuvrer
il fait semblant d avoir un peu écoutés
en fait une manoeuvre
les députés sont bafoués c'est vraiment
un absence totale de respect de la
démocratie
le parti socialiste est tout juste bon à
chaque fois à critiquer en permanence
vous regardez ça finalement dans la
presse papier collé de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
alors ça me désole parce qu'on y est il
ya un divorce de plus en plus grand
entre la société et ses élus on entend
aujourd'hui les gilet jaune d'autres
mouvements recommandé une démocratie
qu'est yeux participative et non plus
électives et malheureusement ce type de
de comportement et bien accrédite dans
l'opinion publique l'idée que les
représentants de la nation de la nation
oui on peut dire de la nation ne font
pas leur travail ou en tout cas se
comportent comme des gamins dans une
cour de récréation moi j'ai été mariée
pendant très longtemps avec un député
eric besson j'avais l'impression que son
travail en circonscription était
extrêmement important c'était un travail
essentiel au service de ses concitoyens
mais que quand il était à l'assemblée
il était souvent confrontés aux
sentiments de d'un pouvoir extrêmement
limité j'avais le droit d'amendement
pour revenir à ce que vous disais à
l'instant le droit d'amendement est un
droit fondamental pour chaque député par
le groupe est pour chaque député a droit
d'obstruction salon de certaines aides
chacun est dans son vrai nom c'est la
soul et il faut pas confondre le droit
d'amendement et le droit à l'objection
dire un amendement ça va si j'ose dire
deux bonjour les dégâts
là il ya un abus comment 40000 se
trouvait à la fin je crois que il faut
pas justement dénaturer les députés les
parlementaires ont un droit d'amendement
puisqu'ils ont perdu l'initiative des
lois donc leur seule manière
d'intervenir de la loi chat c'est de les
amender c'est ça aussi c'est pas le
signe d'une république à bout de souffle
finalement que deux que de faire en
sorte que des députés qui veulent
s'opposer en soit aussi réduits à
utiliser toutes les arcanes tous les
tout les articles de ce règlement en
déposant et parce que c'est pas non plus
ils égalent un maximum d'un moment ces
choses qui n'ont pas toujours finalement
ce qui est inconstitutionnelle c'est
l'abus c'est le détournement de
procédure le détournement de procédure
c'est à dire les amendements sont faits
pour compléter améliorer modifier le
texte
pas pour empêcher le vote du texte mais
là on se trouve sous les on est dans
l'antre havas pour là on est dans
l'entravé l'entravent portent atteinte
aux principes constitutionnels de la
clarté de la sérénité des débats
il ya un détournement de procédure alors
il ya autre chose également qui peut
expliquer je me fais l'avocat du diable
parce qu'à pas de députés de
l'opposition sur ce plateau b c'est ce
sont les délais très restreint de
l'examen de ce texte un qui peut séduire
accéléré maxime procédure accélérée deux
semaines voire trois semaines au maximum
pour examiner ce texte d'importance
est-ce que c'est suffisant le conseil
d'état lui même a mis en garde contre
une forme de précipitation alors là vous
vous touchez un autre débat qui est le
rapport entre le débat parlementaire et
le débat en amont parce que sur la
réforme des retraites
faut quand même pas exagérer il y avait
un débat pendant deux ans avec la
commission delevoye il ya eu des
rencontres avec les syndicats donc
pardon sur le contenu de la réforme
il ya eu un débat mais qui s'est passé à
l'extérieur du parlement
évidemment quand la chose arrive devant
le parlement les parlementaires se
trouve un peu frustré dans la mesure une
bonne partie du débat a eu lieu avant
donc ce qui est en train de se jouer là
c'est le rapport entre démocratie
sociale et démocratie parlementaire
qu'elle
quel parent doit-on laisser aux
parlementaires dans la modification d'un
texte qui a été négocié préalablement
avec les organisations
est-ce que vous êtes comprend qu'un
député puisse considérer qu'il ne peut
pas avoir le dernier mot que c'est pas
normal au fond qu'on lui soumettre un
texte à trous sans financement est ce
que c'est d'arguments là sont recevables
après tout c'est lui qui va te la loi
c'est lui qui vote
c'est pas nécessairement lui qui la
fabrique beaucoup de lois sont fabriqués
par l'administration par les comités de
sages pas et les amendements vous parlez
des amendements les amendements sont
souvent en réalité les parlementaires
sont souvent les porte-paroles
d'amendements qui ont été écrits par des
lobbys que ce soit les lobbys
industriels que ce soit
l'agroalimentaire que ce soit les les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme
les parlementaires quand il dit nous
défendons notre droit d'amendement en
réalité ils défendent la possibilité de
faire passer ce qui vient des lobbys
donc il ya du départ lent et il faut y
être vigilant qu'il faut faut regarder
ça avec un peu de distance
le mot de la fin sophie brunel n'ont pas
ce que ton ce qui nous nourrissent elle
a grandi de votre livre très bonne c'est
que très bonne publicité allait le
message de ce livre au fond c'est
réconcilier vous avec les agriculteurs
qui nous sauveront ses taux aux éditions
buchet chastel pourquoi les paysans vont
sauver le monde
rien que ça merci à vous d'avoir les
jeux de ce d'invités fil rouge dans
cette émission une heure en direct merci
a vous de me découvrir les félidés
pierre revenez quand vous voulez c'est
la fin de cette émission passé une très
belle soirée sur lcp
à demain
[Musique]